would you look at that it seems like we
have ourselves a finished painting so
from our family to yours keep your pants
dry your dreams went and remember hugs
not drugs hey everybody happy holidays
we got some new Deadpool to break down
we finally have a title for the movie
and I wanted to do a video for the
villains which look like they're going
to be the purifiers which also tie in
with Messiah Complex which ties in with
some cable stuff based on the title of
the movie so all the evidence seems to
be pointing towards a couple big things
happening is they're building towards
their x-force team up so if you didn't
know cable and Deadpool are actually the
lead characters for the x-force movie
that Fox has planned that hasn't changed
because of this big Disney buyout I'll
address that at the end of the video but
because there's so many billions of
dollars involved in that it's gonna take
the government more than a year year and
a half to approve that deal meaning that
they're just gonna continue developing
and doing the movies that they
originally planned on doing until told
otherwise when they sign Josh Brolin to
their deal at Fox it was for five movies
and that includes Deadpool to x-force
Deadpool 3 and then potentially two
other sequel movies depending on what
they want to do after Deadpool 3 those
are the two mystery movies are probably
intended to be X for sequels depending
on how well it does because Deadpool is
killing it right now but they haven't
done an x-force movie yet which is
basically their rated-r Deadpool version
of an x-men team up there are a couple
key moments during the trailer that
reveal which comic book villain they're
going with and it's a very Messiah
Complex tie-in character so it sounds
like they're building towards their own
version of that story arc involving hope
and cable but when you see Julianne
Denison standing in this church on fire
with all these reverse Harry Potter
banners in the background talking about
purity it's probably Reverend William
strikers purifiers from the Messiah
Complex storyline where he's basically
trying to purify the human race get rid
of all mutants
so when you see negasonic standing in
front of these very Weapon X
looking carriers in the background those
are probably trucks William strikers
using to round up random mutants
children adults women people that are
too weak to fight back so Deadpool
sounds like he's going to help save
mutant kind albeit without really
intending to because even though we
haven't seen a lot of cable he's really
the person with the plant he comes back
in time wanting to save mutant kind and
Deadpool is just doing his own thing but
he's sort of an [ __ ] with a heart of
gold so obviously it's his movie he
winds up helping out cable albeit after
they fight a little bit with each other
the big thing we don't know here is
whether or not there is actual Hope in
the movie from the Messiah Complex
storyline because even though the
purifiers were big villains of that
series in cable came back to safer
there's a teddy bear on his belt so
there might be a child involved or they
may have just cut her out and he grew up
in this alternate timeline where William
Stryker was successful and he's hunted
mutant kind to extinction the way you
see during the Logan movie so because
there's always lots of Wolverine Hugh
Jackman jokes in the Deadpool movie I'm
expecting a couple Logan jokes because
that was sort of the post-apocalyptic
timeline that we saw during that movie
in William Stryker has been a villain in
so many different x-men movies it makes
sense that they would go back to that
group eventually but as I said in this
movie it sounds like it'll be more like
Reverend William Stryker which is just a
more theatrical version of the character
like the Brian Cox version is more of a
military man this is just a much crazier
version of the Stryker character it
could be someone else but like I said
the purifiers are led by Reverend
William Stryker eddie marsan looks like
he's going to be the main villain and he
resembles kind of a Stryker character so
there could totally be some other actor
playing that character but he's just one
of the few people on the IMDB that has
no listing for who he's playing so I
think they're just trying to keep that
secret the thing that we don't know
though is is what is the emotional
reason why deadpool chooses to help
cable-like is it somebody that he cares
about that ends up getting hurt what it
took in the first movie was the villains
coming for Vanessa the person that he
loved that's why he took action so there
has to be some sort of emotional reason
why Deadpool wants to help cable save
mutant kind there are a lot of you
wondering who jewel
in Denison his playing too you might
remember him from hunt for the will
directed by the person who directed thor
ragnarok that was more of a comedy so
he's more of a comedic actor which makes
sense why they cast him in the movie he
might be playing the butterball
character who just immune to all forms
of harm so it would explain why he can
stand in this burning building without
being heard but just a reminder that
this cable poster the second coming is
actually the same title as the third
story arc in the Messiah Complex trilogy
of stories so it kind of confirms that
they're doing their version of a Messiah
Complex story with a lot of Easter eggs
for the first time the Deadpool and
cable crossed over in New Mutants number
98 that was also the first appearance of
Domino so they'll probably be Easter
eggs for that too
but the story that they're doing is
different from the story of New Mutants
number 98 that was just Deadpool being
hired to kill cable and it was very
simple storyline so speculation maybe
that's how they meet up in this movie
like Deadpool is hired to kill someone
that someone turns out to be cable the
person who hires him might be the
villain of the movie Reverend William
Stryker
so Deadpool goes to kill him then cable
explains why he can't kill him I'm
trying to say mutant kind as a Deadpool
might help him out so just some
speculation but let me know in the
comments if they're doing a Messiah
Complex style story but they have a lot
of characters from the first appearance
of Deadpool how do you think that
they're going to combine all those
things in the movie if they're kind of
doing their own version of it so like
they're not literally going to copy the
Messiah complex story and they're not
going to copy that first appearance of
Deadpool but you'll see a lot of Easter
eggs for both of those things anthem
Attica Lee it will feel a lot like
Messiah Complex but get hype and do not
worry about Deadpool in the MCU if the
deal goes through in 18 months or 2
years or however long it takes to get
clearance from the government if they
don't block it because of antitrust
issues then I think that Marvel will
just create an r-rated label to release
r-rated superhero movies and they'll
just continue on with x-force depending
on how successful Deadpool is but the
CEO of Disney confirm that they will
continue to make rated-r films if this
all goes through but that's a really big
asterisk if
this goes through if it doesn't then fox
is just gonna keep doing the stuff that
it wanted to do before so Deadpool
should be fine
either way no worries just a reminder
that FX is doing an r-rated Deadpool
animated series that's going to premiere
during 2018 they haven't said when it's
gonna debut it's gonna be on FXX
but because they announced the deal
early last year I'm guessing that it'll
take about a year and a half for them to
get the animation out just because that
always takes a long time season 1 is
supposed to be 10 episodes and I'm
optimistic that they're able to start
dropping episodes sometime during the
summer next year but I'll post an update
when we find out more about that
animated series but just a reminder that
it's supposed to be adult animation so
it'll be more like Rick and Morty so no
worries they're not gonna water Deadpool
down but if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's gonna be a whole
bunch more Deadpool footage dropping
earlier in the year obviously we got
infinity war and black panther stuff
dropping too so like the entire first
half of next year is going to be a huge
time for Marvel movies both Fox Marvel
and Marvel Marvel I was gonna talk a
little bit about new Wolverine because
Hugh Jackman confirmed that he's not
coming back but this video went a little
long so I'll just do that in another
Deadpool video while you wait for
everything click here to rewatch the
full Deadpool 2 trailer and click here
for my new infinity war Avengers 4 video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight